Could you please explain anemia causes and how to fix it?
Well, I saw this question. I pulled the blog post right here that I created
to help explain that. I understand one good thing for everybody is to look at if you have a
question, I want you to ask another Zoom call. That's what this is here for.
Many times I'll point you back to a greater explanation.
This blog post, understanding anemia with cancer, it goes into details of what you would see on your
complete blood count and the different types of anemia. You could have anemia of chronic disease,
which is typically an iron deficiency anemia, common in cancers. You could have B12 anemia,
you could have B6 anemia, you could have folate anemia. There's different types of anemia.
The most common is the iron deficiency anemia with cancer patients because cancer can tend to gobble up
iron. This blog post goes into details of what you would see on a CBC and then what you would want
to do with that. I'll refer you to that and refer you to what you have questions. If you don't
want to wait till the Zoom call, always go to our website and there's a little like a little spy
glass or magnifying glass on the right hand side as you're looking at your computer on the website.
If you click on that, you'll go to a search bar and if you just typed in anemia,
you would come up with a bunch of different blog posts on anemia. From this one, understanding anemia
with cancer to anemia, what should I do? Another one, cancer anemia and then frequency programs for anemia,
fatigue, what could cause it, all sorts of different blog posts on that, probably 2,000 blog posts.
Most of them have videos and they are, you know, we try to explain as many things to you as possible.
So I all need to ask them, but sometimes they can go into greater detail if we do have a blog post on it.